that's Craig Lin I'm Joe benon Al CER is your
rinkside reporter great to be back amongst
friends all the men and women in our technical
crew 10 weeks to go in the season petta Drive
is deflected down and wide by arv P scooping
that pass to the short side lingren made a good
save there on Kanda look kovski on it clears for
Suzuki he'll send it out wide to the dangerous
Cole coffe coffe will fire a stick sa for lingren
back with you on Monumental Sports Network off
this turnover a snapshot from scrubble rejected
by lingren the passing game is one of their top
things they have to execute and to do that takes
practice touches move the puck and move it ahead
of the guy don't put it in his skates make it
so it's available with speed Coffield angles
in slser pass score a beautiful feed CR cross
ice and it's jammed to the top shelf by Suzuki
here's the pass in the neutral zone you see melen
Stein trying to feather it there's a giveaway by
doubt in the neutral zone or obey cubel excuse me
and there's that shot and finish and the little
turnover quick transition a beautiful pass by
the way right on the tape notice as it flips
over it's a foot high it's been a sore spot for
Washington getting on the board first as Suzuki
wins this face off back for Jacky Jacky has a lot
of room to Court this one off the post rebound
score Suzuki does it again yeah Miss coverage
in the capital Zone after the face off they
couldn't get out and ex get their players in the
right positions here's the Miss assignment ob's
trying to get out he was interfered off the face
off the puck hit suppos and it lands right onto
the Stick of their Captain for his second goal
of the game two quick goals less than a minute
apart and Montreal has a two- nothing lead
here in the first capitals heading into the
break time had ppgs in three of their last five
aletkin lets this one go easy pickings for monbo
but he flubbed the rebound was quick to cover
and they got off to a good start in that game
remember they scored about a buck 10 or so or less
into that hockey game but couldn't continue to
add to their success van reik stumbles to the
corner trickle there for pizetta and he roofs
one petta makes it three love for Montreal petta
looking like a goal scorer there a bad turnover
a wipe out in the corner a missplay and petta
has got his third of the Season under the bar
of Charlie lingren well you talk about beating
offenses in all three goals they fed them to
the Montreal Canadians this one a wipe out by
TBR down low leads to a loose Puck petta puts
it in the corner they win the draw there's the
top pick and now they move it around and get a
broken play top Corner Suzuki digging in against
Dow off the drop C field waved at there by keer
at the horn Montreal retires to the dressing room
three better than the capitals after the opening
20 arve p on this draw lost H fires up the
post rebounds underneath monmo long enough
for a whistle the referees losing sight of the
puck this must be the post stand because that's
three pipes that were hit two in the first by
Montreal and now uie in the second here it is
the win of the draw hard Lo shot and skips off
that post past the right pad fortunately for the
goalie Mont Ando the puck slides right underneath
that was a pretty good play by sco good reach by
that Defender preventing McMichael to have
any room to get around him oi to the front
deflected monmo just fights that off Patcher
ready on a redirect it remains 3 nothing for
Montreal then a big Collision TJ oosi and Michael
WI out and ran into each other right at the top
of the circles on that play sard giving ground
away from stro the capitals tonight scratching
Ethan bear Alex alexv and Matthew Phillips
as healthy scratches oetkin whirls this one
over top of the head of MBO barari towards a
cage deflection Tri stop rebound score Alex
oetkin Watch What Happens they get it to the
point that shot and there's the Ricochet and
look at that little pass by stroke right under
the tape he has eyes his right eye is looking
out he sees oie that freezes everybody and it's
a wide open net fantastic pass by Dylan stro
who continues to impress he has 32 points on the
season oie in double digit pater ready Waits along
the wall That's Patti to the front door great
save monteo rebounds loose Pat fires oh amazing
defensive play by saard block saves the day here
on their penalty kill here's the pass across it'll
come out watch The Man in the priest there's the
assistant Captain that's why they like him so much
as a great leader for Montreal saard here's the
first save a real good look on both pads off of
Dylan stro in the block garbosa right back to
Trevor yeah they got St Louis Marty St Louis
fourth line tra big time they've been out for a
long time and can't clear backhand chance sck save
monmo faari of late's been going well with
the assists he has a helper now in four of
his last seven including one on the oetkin
tally tonight Evans closing Evans weights
off the curl and drag snapshot score a beauty
from sovi well that's why he was a top pick
overall I mean that is a wicked shot shot right
to the far side and this will make him the man
in Montreal these type of shots just a little
drop pass right here from Evans and then the
shot and it's deadly as he uses farari as a
screen that shot no chance for the goalie to
pick up because of the way he curled it and
then fired it in one motion beating the glove
side of Darcy keer congratulations to Lars he
played his 1,000th game the other night way to
go off this drop Carlson sets it Slap Shot of the
way score goals in backto back games for Rasmus
sandine right off the draw beautiful feed
by Carlson he is one of the best finding the
Wheelhouse he's done it over the years we know
with oetkin but he's got a such a sense not only
the speed but the way he puts it into the right
spot so you don't have to move a whole lot off the
draw strome will get the primary assist along
with John Carlson a Howitzer to the top shelf
Washington looking for more now Carlson closes
fires off the post here after that sandine shot
here's the post from John Carlson short side beats
the glove Alex oetkin turns the other way on the
counter punch three on two develop it beat it
down low inide Wilson and then sprawling mono
a fantastic stop unstone and mono has been very
good nice slight of hands there beautiful passing
Play Obie and Wilson joint and then sandine
just can't tuck once but twice hits him in the
mask then another follow-up shot right there hits
his right leg Suzuki sends in Cofield oh Cofield
on the delay Will Wait along the half board it's
lovsky who has the last Montreal goal mat working
to the outside mat fakes the one timer here it
comes from Sosi another bullet it's 52 33 seconds
in the Box they have a setup and they fire it over
to Sosi and you can see this kid can really bring
it here they set it up little fake by Mattis and
freezes everybody and look at the right side wide
open and he goes Far Side blocker and beats the
goal tender Darcy keer and the Montreal Canadians
have a 5-2 lead l will take the loss on his record
surrendering the first three goals of the game
van rdik scuttles this one in at the final horn
Montreal gets two points this Tuesday night 52